y'all need to respect Matthew Malloy  check this out so Matthew Malloy has the  ability to manipulate reality and change  the nature of the universe at will he  has the ability to do anything including  creating and destroying entire universes  he has knowledge of everything that has  ever happened or will happen he has the  ability to be present everywhere at once  he's immune to aging and death he has  the ability to manipulate time and  travel through it he has the ability to  transport himself anywhere in the  universe instantly he can manipulate and  control energy to a Godlike level he can  manipulate the fundamental nature of  matter that he can resurrect himself  from the dead I don't even know how  somebody does that make sure you guys  follow for more